am i i know but
tetris now
you and i are we
for some reason decided that tetris was
back in the mix we're both
just really hardcore into tetris and
it's just like it takes up like 16 hours
over a day yeah
like the classic one or is there a new
app just on our ipad just yeah but
there's like a three minute one where
you you know i mean and it's like it'll
say
you're ranked number 10 in los angeles
wow and in your head you're like i gotta
get five and you're going down to
craig's be like [ __ ] seat me now
let me get a table yeah
last night
since you don't watch this i want to
recommend something i i've been watching
long lost family again again
you know what it is no i don't i just
love this one
again yeah it was a show on tlc tlc's
got a great show thank you really dude i
like shitty tv 90 day fiance is my jam
yeah oh good just
yeah what's wrong at first sight yes all
those love is blind i don't really watch
it's like i watch shows that are on
flights you know because you fly so much
you're like oh great this is on here but
every once in a while i'll go through
like a phase where i gotta watch it 90
day fiance was that for me i became so
invested in that show and i said like in
high school my parents both went to work
during the summer so i would just watch
like jerry spinner and amari just
sitting on the couch just piece of [ __ ]
just drinking mountain dew watching it
so you didn't watch squid games or
anything that's pop no i didn't because
honestly you got too much hype to the
point where like my levels of
expectation were too high i was like i
don't even want to like all the spoilers
are already out there too much going on
right but that's why i like 90 day
fiance you can flip on any given channel
any given episode and be like oh this is
good
yeah yeah easy to follow yeah who's your
favorite um um couple lately on
90 day
i haven't watched
the newest episode but i will say uh
the necklace guy what's the one we had
on ed dude you know what it was rose uh
that that one's good but there's this
guy he had like he had really intense
like
he's kennedy had really intense like uh
like like bags under his eyes and he was
like a a men's coach
how do i know and he was like dating a
girl like washington
if you type it in but this guy was like
he he taught like male like
strength seminars this guy yes oh my god
you know what i'm a guy from australia
so he's like so he does like uh you
could've said indian dude yeah the guy
said no i don't think you don't have to
do the [ __ ] you know the racoon
i thought he was canadian no he's not
he's from australia
and i think he's actually from mauritius
yeah
and he had the girl but yeah the girl on
the right but like he's like a men's
guru and my the best episode in the
history is he's talking to like nine
women on like why women are dumb right
yeah and
and
how they edit it it's all these dramatic
zooms on these ladies being like there's
there's no dudes here you're bombing
right now that's because his entire
identity was a fraud i just i mean the
whole show was like right but the whole
time i was watching this season i was
like somebody get his thyroid check
because clearly that's except thalamus
this thing the bulging of his eyes yeah
and then the girl is like right now he's
just indian anyway huh
no he was great i did watch tinder swing
there recently though oh we saw that we
love that i just like who calls
everybody's enemies that's
great really just the lady taking your
order in and out enemies
i like that that's fun but long let me
pitch long lost family i mean
it's basically um
you know you won't be for long
no if it's on tls tlc has got some great
shows so it's like you know either it's
either you know somebody was given up
for adoption do you see either the mom
or dad looking for their son
or vice versa
who who is through adoption
like when a when parents give their kid
away or a mother gives their kid away at
birth
and then you know
40 years down the road you know the mom
goes i'm trying to look for my kid so
they find the kid for them and there's a
they reunite